Emmanuel Macron il a été mon
conseiller même avant que je ne devienne
président de la République puis ensuite
quand j'ai été élu par les
Français je connais le talent et c'est
pourquoi j'ai voulu qu'il puisse entrer
au gouvernement il est à sa tâche il
doit seul il doit comme ministre de
l'Économie nous avons vu les enjeux
permettre qu'il puisse y avoir autant de
développement d'entreprise que possible
et autant d' ement que nécessaire il est
d'ailleurs il le fait très bien un
promoteur de l'innovation technologique
c'est sa tâche ensuite qu'il veuilleent
s'adresser aux Français aller chercher
des idées nouvelles aller les convaincre
je ne vais pas l'en empêcher il serait
un bon candidat mais il do je termine il
doit être dans l'équipe sous mon
autorité il l'est oui il est dans
l'équipe et il est sous mon aut vous en
êtes sûr mais j'en suis sûr parce que
c'est entre nous non pas simplement une
question de
hiérarchie il sait ce qu'il me doit
c'est une question de loyauté
personnelle et politique